y habla hablamos de nuestro segundo tema
del día los mexicanos votaron el domingo
10 de abril por la continuidad del
presidente andrés manuel lópez obrador
en la consulta de revocación de mandato
la baja participación fue la gran
protagonista de la jornada pues menos
del 20 por ciento 18 por ciento del
padrón electoral emitió un voto así las
cosas los resultados fueron muy
favorables para andrés manuel lópez
obrador entre un 90 punto tres por
ciento y un noventa y 1.9 por ciento de
los electores que acudieron a las urnas
voto a favor de que continúe en su cargo
los años que le restan de mandato
mientras que entre un 6.4 y un 7.8
prefirieron la revocación según el
instituto nacional electoral el
mandatario celebró lo que calificó como
una jornada histórica y prometió no
defraudar a todo el pueblo mexicano y
para ello para entender entonces lo que
ocurrió este domingo quiero saludar a
nuestro segundo invitado del día el es
álvaro ramírez analista político
especializado en impulsión pública
gracias alvaro por estar con nosotros en
directo américa de frança 4 por supuesto
empieza preguntándole qué lectura se le
puede dar al referendo de revocatoria
liderado por el propio presidente de
lópez obrador éxito o fracaso victoria
derrota
bueno ya raúl e interesante lo que
ocurrió este fin de semana aquí en todo
el país activamente hubo una
participación del 17 7% de 94 millones
de electores eso quiere decir que sólo
16 millones 502 mil ciudadanos se
crecieron ese derecho
15 millones 159 mil enfrentaron al
presidente andrés manuel lópez obrador
sólo un millón 63 mil
y rechazaron que siguiera en el cargo
evidentemente pues es un resultado
favorable para el presidente sin embargo
bien lo mencionas el 80 por ciento 80 y
2.5 por ciento de la población decidió
no ejercer este derecho
sería interesante conocer cuáles fueron
sus intenciones y su motivación aunque
se habla mucho de que la gente no quiso
hacerle el juego al presidente no quiso
prestarse a esta medición intermedia
quisieron también es una cuestión de la
interpretación del propio andrés acción
porque andrés manuel propuso esta
revocación al inicio de su mandato en
2018 cuando llegó al gobierno con 30
millones de votos y hoy 2022
evidentemente ya no podemos hablar de
una coyuntura entonces evidentemente y
si vemos los números francamente tus
perdió el 50 por ciento de elector
álvaro ustedes ya lo hablaba pues vamos
a profundizar que quiso hacer él lópez
obrador con esta idea digamos con este
ejercicio es democrático como lo dijo el
propio presidente ejercicio de
propaganda como lo denuncie la oposición
como usted lo dijo también dependiendo
del lado donde se mire todo lo que
ocurrió este domingo 10 de abril con
esta consulta en mexico
si raúl mira te comentaba que el
escenario electoral con el que el
presidente llega en 2018 evidentemente
ha sido se ha transformado se ha
transformado de tal manera que el año
pasado en las elecciones intermedias el
congreso de la cámara de diputados donde
mayor morena tenía una mayoría de 50 más
uno
perdió precisamente esa mayoría perdió
255 diputados con lo que se ve obligado
a tener una mayor coalición una mayor
necesidad de negociación entonces si
vamos observando evidentemente desde el
2021 el presidente ha venido perdiendo
votos y ya fue ya lo perdió en el
congreso este proceso de revocación del
mandato si bien me permite conocer qué
tanto de su base electoral sigue
manteniendo por otro lado eleva un poco
más la apuesta tanto quienes si quieran
a lear con morena pero también hay que
hay que estudiar los resultados edad por
entidad porque evidentemente ya no se va
a tratar de hacer una sola gran
negociación sino van a hacer 32
negociaciones por los números de
entidades donde evidentemente también
podemos ver que en la ciudad de méxico
hubo una bajísima participación
no
comparado con lo que fue 2018 2021
entonces hay un sentimiento de no
acompañamiento ya podemos decirlo hacia
las propuestas hacia el presidente y lo
que estamos viendo es una movilización
efectiva de las bases de morena que
refrendan ese compromiso no así de la
oposición porque no no me atrevería a
decir otra cosa pero pudo haber sido
distinto el diferente de que se le
revoque el mandato ahora porque está
bajando la popularidad del presidente
andrés manuel lópez obrador como usted
también lo decía y como lo dijo la
oposición al presidente obrador fueron
15 millones las personas que votaron
digamos para que se quede el presidente
obrador hasta finalizar su mandato muy
lejos de los 30 millones que lo votaron
cuando ganó las elecciones
presidenciales que está ocurriendo con
el presidente obrador
mira hay un evidente desgaste del
ejercicio político del ejercicio de
gobierno
hay que recordar que nuestro sistema
presidencial y el periodo de gobierno
sólo es de seis años o sea
se viene un contexto también de reforma
donde sería prudente tal vez modificar
el tiempo de permanencia del presidente
y también quitarnos ese ese trauma
histórico que tenemos los mexicanos de
darle posibilidad de continuidad a un
presidente la reelección porque
pero el presidente evidentemente lo que
estamos viendo en la ciencia política se
habla de un realineamiento electoral que
se habló en 2018 de un realineamiento
pero que hoy vemos que es el
realineamiento no se puede mantener no
se puede sostener para que un
realineamiento sea válido o sea efectivo
se requiere un periodo de tiempo de más
o menos 30 años evidentemente
estamos viendo que ese esos 30 millones
inglés de mantenerse utilizan de rosa el
realineamiento no se está consolidando
por quizá podríamos hablar de una
elección
no sé
eventual coyuntural porque lo que va a
ser interesante es que para 2010 y 24
esos 15 millones quizá no sigan siendo
los 15 millones de devotos estos 15
millones se parecen más a la votación
efectiva de andrés manuel lópez obrador
en 2006 y 2012
a la multiplicación que tuvo en 2018 por
eso yo insisto en decir que esto es un
2018 fue una lección coyuntural hoy
estamos viendo los números que andrés
manuel siempre tuvo en las dos
elecciones anteriores y que e insisto va
a elevar la apuesta va a elevar el costo
de la negociación política para la
elección de 2004